bonsoir nouvelle édition du 7 8 une
heure pour faire le point sur
l'actualité locale en direct entre 18 et
19 heures le premier invité qui va nous
accompagner ce soir jean-luc vestiaires
bonsoir le président de l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin l'université de
versailles saint quentin à l'heure des
choix actuellement se met en place le
campus paris saclay qui va permettre de
fusionner plusieurs centres de recherche
des entreprises également votre
université doit-elle en faire partie et
surtout à quel prix vous nous le dire et
tout à l'heure auparavant le sommaire de
ce 22 novembre en images à présent les
sujets à suivre ce soir la mobilisation
et des salariés des caisses
d'allocations familiales les caf étaient
closes aujourd'hui parmi les
revendications l'arrêt des suppressions
de postes d embauche en cdi les réserves
de sang toujours trop faible pour faire
face aux besoins le centre de
prélèvement ile de france ouest
multiplient les opérations au plus près
des populations pour préparer la fin de
l'année urbanisme la déviation de la rd
98 rd 11 avril pour les clayes-sous-bois
et plaisir est opérationnel une
déviation en zone agricole pour mieux
desservir la zone commerciale et puis
pour finir la semaine quelques précieux
conseils par marie thérèse roussel et
présidente du réseau qu'ahmad pour le
maintien à domicile comment se relaxer
facilement chez soi on débute par les
agriculteurs des yvelines et de
l'essonne toujours en colère le
collectif sauvons les yvelines été reçue
en préfecture en fin de journée et ils
ne veulent pas voir les exploitations
coupée en deux par la future 4e rocade
qui reliera la seine aval à saint
quentin en yvelines un bon soir à
philippe heurtevent président du
collectif mère d'auteuil le roi dans les
yvelines vous êtes en ligne avec nous ce
soir
bonsoir vous aviez déjà manifestés sur
versailles il ya quelques semaines vous
avez défilé également dans les rues
versaillaise avec des tracteurs avant
d'être reçus par le préfet michel jau
nouvelle réunion cet après-midi une
réunion qui vient tout juste de se
terminer que s'est il dit cet après midi
en fin d'après-midi faux
qu'effectivement la coordination rurale
a été reçu aujourd'hui avec le collectif
sauvons les yvelines et nous avons avec
le préfet et les services suite à la
manifestation du 22 septembre à bord d
un certain nombre de sujets qui avaient
été donc soulevé lors de cette réunion
du 22 je vous je passe la parole à jean
noël roi star qui est donc le président
de la coordination agricoles des
yvelines et qui va donc vous exposez
quelles sont les positions qui ont été
prises aujourd'hui alors vous avez passé
la porte n'était pas prévu on devait
vous avoir comme intervenant donc bon
soir à l'autre intervenant qui est
également avec une en ligne vous les
avez représenté monsieur richard
président de l'union des syndicats de la
coordination alors dites nous ce qui
s'est dit concrètement cet après midi
que s'est il passé dans cette réunion
avec le préfet ce qui vous avait été
entendu en voilà sur le premier point
nous avons parlé donc d abattoir mobile
pour permettre à tout élevage de
survivre en ile de france voire même de
relancer l'activité pour le
développement des circuits courts
la soupe de deuxième point
l'assouplissement des normes
environnementales pour le maintien des
exploitations en concertation avec la
profession agricole
la présente nous avons aussi parlé la
préservation des espaces agricoles en
ile de france l'urbanisation par
densification des communes dans leurs
feintes
en ce qui concerne les infrastructures
routières qui ferait manquer les
exploitations nous sommes tout à fait
opposés exemple pour la liaison -
saint-quentin alors justement on y vient
c'est le point principal et je vais vous
demander d'être heureux d'être très bref
parce que le temps passe et il faut
compter une avance 6 1 dites nous si
vous avez été entendues notamment sur
cette 4e rocade qui vous inquiète qui
plus est les exploitations de
été entendu effectivement sur cette
raison parce que le conseil général
continue le projet de cette
infrastructure
il ya eu le maintien aussi des chemins
de plaine dans la configuration actuelle
nous sommes opposés aussi aux voix
bétonné et autre chose aussi c'est
l'opposition au complexe sportif du cip
du pg sur les espaces agricoles de la
commune de poids fille d'une surface de
30 hectares en terres fertiles donc sur
ces différents points pour préserver les
espaces agricoles juste pour conclure si
vous n'avez pas été entendu et ce que
vous allez mener encore d'autres actions
d'autres mobilisations coup de poing
selon thomas qui ont des décennies
5 nous avons été entendus par monsieur
le préfet ni et qu on lui a demandé
c'est nous c'est la reconnaissance de
l'agriculture en zone péri urbaine afin
que l'aménagement du territoire soit
réalisé en concertation avec les
organisations professionnelles
professionnels notre souhait c'est de
vivre dignement du métier d'agriculteur
sans dépend des subventions qui
induisent des contrôles et donc vous
restez mobilisés imaginons c'est tout à
fait mobilisés et nous avons prévu
d'autres actions syndicales dans le mois
de décembre que ne manqueront pas de
relayer merci d'avoir été en ligne avec
nous donc agriculteurs et yvelinois
également de l'essonne qui restent
mobilisés notamment contre l'axé routier
et puis plus globalement vous l'avez
entendu ce soir contre les différents
projets qui menace les terres agricoles
je vous le disais en titre portes closes
ce matin sur l'ensemble du territoire
français pour les caisses d'allocations
familiales comme à guyancourt vous allez
en voir les images à l'appel notamment
de la cgt et de force ouvrière les
salariés étaient en grève afin d'obtenir
à l'arrêt des suppressions d'emplois ou
encore l' embauche en cdi de nouveaux
agents 1000 postes en moins ont été
recensés en trois ans des salariés qui
entendent également interpellé le
gouvernement sur la dégradation du
service apporté alors que de nouvelles
demandes d'allocation ne cessent
d'affluer en raison de la crise
économique qui touche les ménages voilà
pour cette information passe à présent à
notre fait du jour et l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines à
l'heure du choix